each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
diversity and he's going to be talking
to us today about a topic near and dear
to my heart abstraction and it'll tell
us a little bit about data data
abstraction so welcome ok so the title
of my talk is data abstraction without
transition abstraction which in the
interest of full disclosure I should say
is not the title I sent around on my
abstract but I think this is a better
fit for the ideas I want to talk about
so sorry about that before i get into
the main content of my talk I wanted to
briefly outline the software model
checking effort at BYU there's two
faculty myself and Eric Mercer for PhD
students rahul kumar who's here as an
intern now and talk about who's visiting
with me today as well and then they
haruna who's working on heuristics for
guided model checking and i'll talk a
little bit about how her work relates to
these ideas in a minute her work isn't
directly related to abstractions will
kind of skip over that and Kevin
Simonson who's working on disk based in
parallel methods for LTL model checking
and we have three master students Joel
jutin and Joseph and two undergraduates
as well so I want to give a brief
introduction to the idea of model
checking not so much to teach you what
it is but more to set up the terminology
a little bit and set up some of the
issues I want to talk about so the model
checking problem the way out the way I
want to phrase it is the problem you're
given three things the first is a
transition relation T which given a
state tells you what are the next states
of the system under test or next state
and an initial state asked which is just
the initial state of the system and a
property P to be checked and the goal of
amalah the problem of model checking Ben
is to determine if the transition system
starting at state ass is a model of some
property P that the transition system is
supposed to satisfy
so in software model checking the
transition system t is defined by an
interpretation of a program so you're
given a program text let's say it's a
C++ or C program text and you interpret
that in a way that gives you a
transition relation and that transition
relation is the thing that's going to be
verified against some property for some
given initial state so one of the key
ideas and software model checking is
data abstraction data abstraction is
important for two reasons the first
reason is that in some interpretations
of program text variables are allowed to
range over the integers so there's a
infinite data space for the variables
and model checking over infinite data
spaces introduces new problems with like
decidability and representation so it's
nice to avoid that idea by using an
abstraction that gets away from infinite
data domains even if you do pretend the
variables have a finite domain then
software model checking is still
difficult mostly because of a
combinatorial explosion and the number
of different variable values that need
to be considered so the idea then is to
replace the domain the original domain
of the variables with a smaller domain
and in predicate abstraction the idea is
to replace all the variables with
predicates which have a two valued
domain which is convenient so the
transition abstraction in model checking
goes something like this so each
instruction in a program can be viewed
as a single transition in this
transition graph so there's this
transition system that one is trying to
verify and one way to look at software
model checking is that each instruction
is its own transition so in a transition
abstraction which is often forced by a
data abstraction the idea is to replace
each of the original transitions using
whatever interpretation you wanted for
your software with some transition over
the abstract data variables that has
either the same behavior or more more
behavior so that you can end up saying
something meaningful about your
verification result in the end and I'll
go through an example
that describes us in a little more
detail so the main idea that I want to
get across in my talk is that being able
to do data abstraction for software
model checking without requiring a
transition abstraction avoids a problem
and that problem is the problem of
determining what a program actually
means during the data abstraction phase
so the problem of determining what a
program actually means it's kind of a
subtle tricky problem in certain
contexts and I'll kind of get into that
but the main idea here is that we want
to be able to do a data abstraction for
software model checking because that's
absolutely essential for things like
scalability and termination but we want
to avoid this problem of doing a
transition abstraction and now I'll go
through an example that makes this idea
I hope a little more precise so here's a
simple program excuse me here's a simple
program that has one variable X we start
by assigning X to a value a little while
loop here so while x is less than this
other value which is about 2 billion and
change we increment X and continue
through this wild loop so one way to
abstract this program using a predicate
abstraction is to pick a predicate say Q
and Q simply search that X is less than
this value and then given this predicate
we rewrite the transitions of the
program to create a new program which
I'll call p2 and in this new program P
to each transition in the original
program is replaced by a transition in
the new program such that the new
transition T prime operates on the
abstract variable and here's the tricky
part this new transaction this new
transition T prime has the same effect
on the truth values of Q as the
transitions in T do as the transition to
do in p1 so this transition T prime has
two properties operates on the abstract
values and it computes the same effect
on the truth values of the abstract
values as the original transition does
and I'll briefly go through how that
looks for this program so the two
interesting bits are right here the
guard in the wild
and the instruction that increments X so
the guard on the while loop conveniently
enough is just the predicate that I
picked so I can replace the guard on the
wild with just the truth value of the
predicate and then the way that this is
read is that when I increment X over
here that has an effect on cue and this
tuple means that if Q is true going into
this instruction then the first value
gives the value of Q after this
instruction and the second value on the
other hand if Q is false going into this
instruction then the second value gives
the value of Q after the execution of
incrementing X so the way that works is
that if Q is true going into this
instruction then Q is either true or
false after x is incremented because Q
is simply asserts that x is less than
some value if I'm from an accent may or
may not remain less than that value on
the other hand if q is greater that I'm
sorry if x is greater than this value
before I increment X the next will
continue to be greater now I could have
simplified this a little bit because I
know that Q is true when I come into
this instruction but I wanted to kind of
get it all in one place so that you know
that works fine so what I've done is
I've replaced these transitions with
transitions over here that have the same
effect on cue as this transition would
have 1q so here's another simple program
it's the same basic program except this
time I'm going to assert at the end that
x is greater than one and I've added a
couple new predicates I'm setting this
example up very carefully to create a
problem which you'll see in about two or
three slides so I've picked three
predicates same basic program with an
assert statement you if I interpret this
program using unbounded integers as my
model of how software works then I'll
get a boolean program or a program over
these boolean values that represent the
truth values of these predicates that
look something like this so the
interesting bit here is what happens
when x is incremented so when x is
incremented q behaves as before r if r
was true before x is incremented that is
if x is greater than zero before x was
implemented then it remains true
afterwards if our was false before x is
incremented
may or may not be false afterwards and
similarly s is true if s was true before
x is incremented then it's true
afterwards and if s was false before X
was incremented then it simply takes on
the value of r afterwards so if we draw
out the if we draw out the transition
graphs for these two programs then we
get to transition graphs that look
something like this assuming we
interpret the program over the unbounded
set of integers so X simply increments
along until it reaches a value that
violates this guard we assert that x is
greater than 1 this value is greater
than 1 so the assertion passes on the
other hand for the abstracted program
with the abstract transitions execution
can kind of bounce around in this loop
for a while eventually it will bounce
over to this other value and then
eventually the assertion will pass
because I can't exit this loop until so
I have to when I exit this loop the
value of s is always true my assertion
was just asked which is that x is
greater than one so when I come out of
this loop the assertion always passes so
what I've done here is I've created an
abstract version of this program that
captures the meaning of this program
under its interpretation / unbounded
integers the problem is that when i run
this when i interpret this program on
say a processor with 32-bit signed
integers then the interpretation of the
program is different because this value
right here just happens to be maxent
plus one which ends up in a signed
32-bit representation being negative
maxent so the while loop is actually
never executed and the assertion fails
at the end so just in case you don't
believe me here it is on my laptop so
here's that program in C so what I did
is I wrote the limit down as Max in and
then I added one to it as a variable so
the compiler wouldn't warn me that I was
about to exceed the maximum size of the
variable so I didn't want to see that
warning and I was trying to set up an
example all right so then i do the while
loop do the assertion and the assertion
fails so the point I'm trying to make
here is that if a data abstraction
require
transition abstraction which predicates
abstraction does when done this way then
the transition abstraction has to be
done then the transition abstraction is
only as good as the interpretation that
one takes of the software under test so
in this case if I assumed that integers
truly were unbounded then my transition
abstraction captures that fact and
integers behave as though they're
unbounded however if I execute the
program on say a 32-bit architecture
with 32-bit signed integers then my
original interpretation of the program
doesn't match the interpretation of the
program on the hardware that I executed
it on so this is just a very simple
example I mean there's lots of different
ways you could avoid this problem that
are that are really straightforward but
the the point I'm trying to make is that
interpretation and predicate abstraction
is an important thing so typically it's
done using a C program text with a set
of predicates and the C language
definition with the caveat that the
integers are typically treated as
unbounded that's translated into a
series of theorem prover calls which
eventually result in a booing program at
the other end now there's also an
opportunity for transitions to be
further mangled in these theorem prover
calls but that that's just how theorem
proving is and not that's ok so in
reality the way the semantics work and I
put reality in quotes because I work at
a university and we never really deal
with reality in the first place so the
way it works in reality is somebody took
the C language definition along with the
target instruction set architecture
definition and came up with a C compiler
that hopefully preserves this definition
under that definition the C program text
is given to the compiler get an
executable and then there's some
behavior on a silicon processor ideally
the behavior of the instruction set
architecture on the silicon processor is
the same as the instruction set
architecture definition that the c
language that the compiler writer used
but you can see that there's lots of
opportunities for the meaning of a
program text to be different than the
meaning of a program text as it was used
in abstraction so the goal of our work
is to be able to do data abstraction
because that's a critical thing
but to do data and abstraction in a way
that avoids the necessity of extracting
transitions and here's four reasons why
I think that's a good idea the first is
that it avoids the problem of
understanding what the program
transitions do in the first place so if
you want to stay close to the meaning of
a program on an actual piece of hardware
it's actually a hard problem to know
what a program transition does because
while given a C program text because the
compiler is going to introduce some new
behavior the actual behavior of the
machine code on the processor might
introduce some new behavior and then if
you throw concurrency and it gets even
more difficult because more often than
not well I shouldn't say that because a
single see instruction can be rendered
to several machine code instructions and
if your processor allows interleaving at
the machine code level then see
instructions are going to be interleaved
in a way that's really hard to predict
but just what that's real that's
somewhat difficult to predict by looking
at the sea program text alone so by
avoiding transition abstraction during
the data abstraction phase we avoid this
whole problem of understanding what the
transitions do the other thing that's
nice about avoiding transition
abstraction is that we can deal with
complex data operations so if you're
using a theorem prover to understand
what your transitions due to the
abstract variables then you're sort of
limited by what the theorem prover can
do so for example if you want to do
things like multiply variables and
compare their values to each other then
you sort of stepped into an undecidable
theorem proving problem and your theorem
proving will be less less accurate
because it you know it might be able to
figure it out through constant
propagation in some cases but the
theorem proving is not going to be able
to support you as much as it could have
otherwise so by avoiding this transition
abstraction step we don't worry about
the complexity of the data operations
because we just execute them with their
real values and it doesn't really matter
I mean the goal of transition
abstraction is generally to provide an
overall summation of the underlying
concrete synaptics rights somehow you
have a difficult yeah so we took there's
two approaches to this problem that I'll
talk about the first is just a dead
variable analysis that we perform during
model checking and that ends up giving
us the exact transition relation that we
started with so we end up without any
under approximation at all or over
approximation on the other hand if we do
the other abstraction technique is
karina pass Soriano's predicate
abstraction technique and that does end
up with an under approximation in the
end but it's a predictable not
predictable but it's an under
approximation that you can measure and
no know how bad it was does that answer
your question is that kind of all right
then come back to that the other reason
to avoid transition abstraction is that
if you don't have to understand what the
program actually does then you can use
the actual execution engine that's going
to execute the program to tell you what
the program actually does and this is
kind of the philosophy behind the job of
pathfinder that came out of NASA so
rather than build a semantic model of
Java programs you just think hey I've
got this java virtual machine that's
going to assign a semantics to my
program while I just use out asthmatics
for my program and you can do that by
instrumenting the Java Virtual Machine
to act like a model checker and we did
that as well in a tool called estes hour
to last us basically uses the ganute
debugger and we instrumented the canoe
debugger to act like a model checker so
now we get the semantics of binary
executables as interpreted by the canoe
debugger and so that avoids the whole
problem of figuring out how machine code
gets executed how the interleaving is
going to happen and all that and the
other nice thing about avoiding
transition abstraction is it sets up
this really nice method of reasoning
about software components that I'll get
into at the end of my tongue
so I kind of gave an introduction to
this idea of data and transition
abstraction and why we want to separate
the two the next thing I'll do is talk
about a data abstraction that we
developed that we call dynamic dead
variable analysis and then I'll talk
about an idea for component abstraction
based on this so very briefly one
approach to model checking is explicit
model checking an explicit model
checking you have a queue of states that
are waiting to be expanded under the
transition relation and a table of
states that have already been visited or
expanded and a transition relation which
basically boils down to a function that
given a state returns a set of states
that are than the successors for that
state so this is the successor relation
so in explicit model checking one of the
fundamental limiting factors is the
number of states you can fit in this
table of visited States the reason you
need a table of visited states is to
avoid duplicate work and to detect
termination so this ends up just being a
big giant hash table and memory that
often exceeds memory so the goal of data
abstraction in this case is to make this
table smaller there's two main ways to
make this table smaller one is to put
fewer states in it and one is to make
the state you put in it smaller and this
particular approach to data abstraction
will do both so typically called dead
variable analysis a live variable
analysis but we're focused on dead
variables so we call it a dead variable
analysis so dead variable analysis and
model checking is a pretty simple
analysis that has a positive impact so
it appears in these model checkers boga
or if and spin so the goal is to do a
data and path abstraction without a
transition abstraction and the nice
thing about this data abstraction is
that the complexity of the underlying
data operation 20 relevant because we're
going to do the data abstraction using
actual values at runtime rather than
using symbolic values before runtime so
we don't have to use a theorem proved or
any other analysis technique to try to
figure out what the data manipulations
do
so briefly a variable V and a variable V
is dead at a program point P if this
temporal logic formula is satisfied and
that is that variable V at program point
P is a model of this formula and this
formula says that along all paths
starting at P V is defined releases the
obligation for V not to be used in the
future along that path which is just a
temporal logic way of saying that a
variable is vet dead if it's either
redefined before its next use or not
used at all so here's the variable V
here's a location P it's redefined on
this path before its next use it's not
defined it all along this path so this
variable is dead at this location so one
way that you could improve dead variable
analysis is that instead of computing
that instead of determining whether or
not a variable is dead overall pass
through a control flow graph you might
want to determine whether or not a
variable is dead along all feasible
paths in a control flow graph under a
given valuation of the program state so
you can improve dead variable analysis
by checking it using this formula right
here and this formula says that a
variable V is dead at program point P
for variable evaluation Sigma if it is a
model of this temporal logic formula and
this temporal logic formulas says that
along all paths that are feasible for
this variable valuation V is redefined
before it's next use or not used it on
so pictorially here's what that looks
like here's p here's a variable
valuation that assigns x to the value 20
and then assigns a bunch of values to
the other availables that we don't
really care about the end of this basic
block basic block to here has an if
statement and let's say that the guard
on that if statement is that x is
greater than 20 I'm sorry that's 10 says
if x is greater than 10 so if x is
greater than 10 we go down this branch
otherwise we go down this branch so
using this valuation sensitive debt
variable analysis at runtime we can
figure out that this branch is
infeasible for this variable valuation
so although V is used along this branch
this branch is infeasible so we can
ignore it this is the only feasible
branch and V is not used along that
branch I'm sorry it's defined before
it's used along that branch so V is dead
under that variable valuation it's
pretty straightforward idea so that
gives rise to a model checking algorithm
that looks something like this start off
by doing a dead variable analysis to get
what we can't for all paths not just the
feasible ones start model checking every
now and then and it turns out that
really getting precise about what we
mean by every now and then is an
interesting problem but every now and
then we stop model checking run a
forward simulation using the current
valuation of all the variables in the
program to prune the control flow graph
and then run a dead variable analysis on
the prune control flow graph and then
repeat at step two so the idea is that
in step 5 we can mark more variables
dead store fewer store less stuff in the
table of visited States and explore
fewer pass through the program so
there's two main problems with that
algorithm as I presented it the first is
that merging incomplete forward
simulation information with backward
analysis starting at the exit is is a
little tricky and I'll get that I'll
talk about that in a second the other is
the dead variable analysis information
is now valuation sensitive so rather
than statically annotating the control
flow graph with the sets of dead
variables for every basic block the sets
of dead variables for each basic block
now change depending on the valuation of
the program variables so it's not that
hard to manage that information but it's
a trickier problem to manage it
efficiently in a way that doesn't
significantly slow model checking I'm
going to skip over that part of the
algorithm but I'll talk about that
so the first issue is merging the
depth-first search information which is
how we do the forward simulation with
the variables in the current program
evaluation and the dead variable
analysis so here's a little I example of
how that works so let's say we're in
basic block one and decide to stop model
checking and do a forward simulation to
prune the control flow graph now in this
forward simulation to prune the control
flow graph there's a bit of an
engineering decision which needs to be
made about how far to do this forward
simulation so in the one hand it could
be done all the way to the exit and we
could get the most pruning on the other
hand it could be done one step and get
the least pruning but be the fastest so
we set that up as a parameter to our
system and kind of played with it to see
what would happen and it turns out that
the problem of determining how far to go
and forward simulation is a little more
subtle than we had first anticipated so
let's pretend we go from basic block 12
basic block 5 during forward simulation
and we're able to figure out that only
this branch is feasible that that branch
is not feasible so the problem is that a
standard dead variable analysis would
start at the exit point and is a
backwards dataflow analysis so proceed
backwards through the control flow graph
to figure out which variables are dead
along which paths through the control
flow graph unfortunately our forward
simulation didn't make it all the way to
the exit so we need a way to merge the
information about which branches were
taken during the current program
valuation and which branches must be
taken to make each part of the control
flow graph reachable so the way we did
that is before model checking we perform
a dataflow analysis with a bit vector
and that bit vector has a single bit for
every branch in the program and we
compute a fixed point on the outcome of
each conditional and how it affects the
reach ability of each block so for
example block 3 here is reachable only
if branch to evaluates to true
and block 5 is reachable only if branch
to evaluates to true similarly for block
7 block 9 is reachable and it doesn't
really matter which outcome we had for
branch to and it doesn't really matter
what the outcome was for the branch at
basic block 6 either so you can see that
like since there's a loop over here it
really doesn't matter what the outcome
is for basic at the end of basic block 6
because each of these three blocks are
ultimately reachable for each outcome of
that branch so it's a pretty
straightforward dataflow analysis to try
to figure out which branches affect the
reach ability of which basic block may
be so um tell me why yeah yeah yeah
let's talk about that offline so the way
I came up with data dependence analysis
was I pulled my favorite compilers book
out after we designed our analysis
algorithm and said what does that look
the most like so yeah I could go we
should talk about that offline because I
would be interested so then during model
checking we keep track of which branches
actually were taken given the current
program evaluation so I'm a Microsoft
how do I make that go away I don't know
if I'll just kind of suck it all right
all right good so I'm sorry about that
so what we do is during dead variable
analysis we check the decisions that
must be made to reach a basic block
against the decisions that were made to
reading forward simulation to prune out
paths and in this particular figure the
decisions that must be made are shown in
black and the decisions that were made
are shown in blue and the evolution of
the backwards analysis for dead variable
analysis is shown in green
so basically going from 10 to 9 the
outcome of two doesn't matter using this
particular program evaluation Brent the
branch at the end of basic block 2 ended
in true which is consistent with doesn't
matter so the analysis proceeds along
this branch the outcome of the branch at
the end of basic walk to must be false
to reach this basic block the outcome of
the branch at to was true so this branch
can be pruned however along this branch
it's consistent so it marches all the
way up to the top and only this part of
the control flow graph is considered in
the dead variable analysis so really the
pruning of the control flow graph and
the merging of the information from the
forward simulation is all done on the
fly and it's just kind of a one-pass
thing through the control flow graph so
the second algorithm looks something
like this the first thing we do is go
through and do this analysis to annotate
the basic blocks with branch outcomes
then we do a standard dead variable
analysis to mark the stuff that's always
dead start model checking every now and
then stop when we stop we do a forward
stimulation to collect branch outcomes
and we run a static debt variable
analysis algorithm while pruning the
control flow graph based on those branch
algorithms and then we go back to step 2
using our enriched set of dead variables
and things worked out well the details
about how we manage the content of the
valuation sensitive dead variable
information is in our paper at peplum
from January of this year the punchline
is that it's really efficient and cool
and only uses memory when it has to and
freeze memory whenever he can so we
coded this thing up when I say we I mean
Michael Lewis who's recently hired into
the office group so we coded this thing
up in our estes model checker estes is a
machine code model checker uses explicit
state enumeration with gdb to evaluate
programs which like i was saying before
saves us the trouble of understanding
what binary programs do it all it
requires an environment model provided
by the user for off-chip inputs so we
set gdb up and I'm sorry we set asked us
up in
initially for embedded processors so we
used a small motorola processor for all
of these results the one caveat about
our algorithm that you might not have
expected is that our dynamic dead
variable analysis during verification
actually gives up a points of non
determinism and the reason it gives up a
points of non determinism is because
then we would have to save and reason
about branches of reachable path
information rather than straight line
flows of reachable path information
which clutters up the algorithm a little
bit I don't think it would be a
difficult extension to deal with trees
of feasible branches rather than just
just straight line path so we tested
this idea out on four different programs
these are the four programs I'll talk
about more than more in a second they
were written in C we compiled them with
the GCC compiler for the motorola 6800
oven and our objective here was to
compare dynamic dead variable analysis
for model checking with this standard
static dead variable analysis for model
checking we wanted to see what the
time-space overhead of our technique was
if we actually marked more variables
dead if we explored fewer states and if
we actually saved any space in the size
of that table of visited States so
here's the results dining philosophers
is surprisingly dining philosophers the
way we intima implemented it had one
loop and no pointers the reason I
mentioned on each one of these programs
kind of what the pointers looked like is
because in a static dead variable
analysis pointers are a little tricky to
deal with because it's not exactly clear
at static analysis time what the
pointers are pointing to so you kind of
have to pretend it's either the whole
working set of the program or all of
memory or just the memory you can get to
without an access violation but during
execution time all those pointers can be
disambiguated so you can get a lot of a
bit more pruning out of the of the
analysis so this dining philosophers
problem was kind of not a good problem
for dynamic dead variable analysis
because it has no pointers so you can
see that this over
top line is model checking this problem
with no data abstraction through static
or dead variable analysis static or
dynamic dead variable analysis takes
about a second to verify it explore 7722
states hash tables that big this overlay
size measures how much extra memory the
dynamic dead variable analysis needed to
store these evaluations sensitive dead
variable sets so the thing here is that
dynamic dead variable analysis saved no
time saved no memory and cost no memory
it actually cost some time but you know
it's wicked oh thank you for a whole
sorry about that the distinction is that
there's a lot of different parameters to
a dynamic dead variable analysis one of
the things we did is we set it up so
that the amount of forward simulation we
did get to be controlled by parameter
and so we tried 14 different
combinations of the parameters this was
the one that ran the fastest and this
was the one that ran the slowest so
rather than like increasing the length
of this table by 56 we just reported to
actually it would be 38 I guess because
we already have two lines burn all right
so so that's dining philosophers this
was kind of a nice example of something
where our analysis got no reduction did
nothing useful all did was cost time and
it you know kind of almost doubled the
running time which wasn't great but it
didn't cost us any more memory and
explicit model checking memories really
the main problem you know the good
people I didn't tell will help us solve
the time problem every chip release so
bulls and cows is a little game it's a
one-player game has three loops and a
few pointers so you can see that we're
getting a little bit of reduction here
so we we took the hash table size down
from 211 kilobytes to 209 which is you
know maybe not something to really write
home about but it's a small problem
anyway so a small reduction on small
problems fairly reasonable
and it cost us Oh point one four
kilobytes and overhead to keep track of
our valuation sensitive dead variables
and you can see that the running time
came down a little bit but not not not a
lot timed SSC is a it's an interrupt
driven program that updates variables we
also had to deal with variable uses and
definition and interrupts and I'll kind
of skip over that but that's in the
paper as well and we got a little bit
more reduction things are starting to
look better there though what we did is
we designed the program that's the ideal
program for this kind of analysis and
here's what it looks like so this is a
control flow graph these are basic
blocks we have eight variables X 1 X 2
and X 8 that are defined in this basic
block and each basic block ends in a
guard of the form X 5 times x 6 is less
than x 7 times X 8 and then this at this
level the basic blocks end in a
conditional of the form X 7 is less than
X 8 and then at the lowest level each
basic block includes a single use of
each variable so at compile time it's
difficult to figure out which variables
are actually going to get used in any of
these paths down to exit but during
execution time it's pretty
straightforward to evaluate the outcomes
of all those multiplications and prune
the control flow graph down to a single
path so now we can mark seven out of
eight variables dead and get a nice
reduction in the state space of the
program and we can make that reduction
arbitrarily large by increasing the
range of the variables we didn't play
that game a lot but we could have we
could have made ourselves look even
better so the the nice thing about this
result is that this result says that in
the ideal case we actually got the
reduction we were expecting in these
non-ideal cases we kind of got meager
results so the nice thing here is that
the hash table size went down from 52
kilobytes to 13 kilobytes in the best
case the running time went down by a
third and the number of states explored
went down by about a factor of three as
well
the reason for that is that if all the
variables are live along this path then
we have to explore this path for each
value of all of the live variables
however if we mark all of the variables
dead well if we mark more of the
variables dead than we have to explore
this path fewer times and that's exactly
what we observed in the execution of the
program I'm going to skip that slide so
the summary of this part of the talk is
that what we set out to do is create a
data abstraction for arbitrarily complex
transitions that is anything you can
evaluate with gdb we can shove through
this is okay for under this data
abstraction we use gdb to provide the
program semantics which is convenient
because it includes all the warts that
the implementation of the ISA includes
and all that funky stuff that the
compiler does ends up being in our
semantic model for the software we're
verifying and if you're actually going
to run the software then you care about
things like that it works well for
certain program structures so the deal
is that if your program looks like
something like that then this is
probably a good analysis if it doesn't
then this isn't so useful so the next
step in the work is to design heuristics
that analyze the control flow graph
before model checking time and figure
out when to do this analysis and way not
to do this analysis that's correct for
example you were saying that you know
you were proving that some branch was
always true sure so um I guess since
you're doing it with concrete X but I'm
not clear how you're doing that without
the use of a theraflu oh yeah basically
see some execution it takes the branch
it always takes the rash true but maybe
there's some other and put that makes
the ranch go boss so it wasn't there to
be sure with so there's two issues there
the first one is that when I'm have my
program and I'm in this state where let
me get a different color and skin
so when I'm right here in execution I
know all the values for all these
variables so actually evaluating this
guard I mean you just send it off to the
processor and it gives you back yeah
okay good so then the thing is that when
I've evaluated this guard for these
values and pruned my control flow graph
for these values so let's say maybe only
this part is reachable that's all I know
if I get a different set of if I have a
different set of values later on and I
reach this basic block again with a
different set of values I have to redo
all of that I mean it's it's like a very
narrow theorem proving result so it's a
theorem proving result that tells me the
branching structure of my program for a
single valuation of the variables so if
I want to do that symbolically for like
lots of valuations of the variables then
I'll need it there and prove your step
and then I'll need to that's exactly
right and so that's the second problem
with this work is that now all of our
dead variable information is sensitive
to the variable valuations that you gave
basically in the world of doing you know
dynamic data flow analysis on the path
to your program which you know people do
so it's it's not the question is what
are you using the results of your
analysis for it if you're coming to your
code duplication and you know Pilar
optimization you can split out that path
take care of
episode especially a red special yeah I
mean all we're using a forest to avoid
sticking stuff in the hash table so
we're not emitting code at the end or
anything it's just a thing I guess I was
just yeah so in the in the beginning
sort of you talk about model checking in
the problem of transitions and so I was
a little confused because my I was
thinking about proving properties and
and here in this with this forward
simulation which is concrete execution
you're not you're not getting a proof
pearl for all paths you're getting
you're getting precise and data flow
information along along say a hot path
and insights so I just I just has a
disconnect between the first part of the
second good any other questions all
right great
so one of the problems with the way
though oh I should I should mention this
so the overall philosophy in this
particular piece of work from an
analysis point of view is it to take an
idea from static analysis that you might
use in a compiler and adapt it to the
situation that one finds oneself in in
model checking so in model checking the
actual model checking of a piece of
software is so complementation alee
costly that sort of a expensive analysis
like this actually makes sense and saves
time in the long run and so we took a
similar approach to guided model
checking so in guided model checking you
have this control flow graph and certain
parts of the control flow graph contain
assertions where the properties that
you're trying to check might fail so the
idea is to drive the execution of the
model checker towards those basic blocks
so that you can check the assertions
more often and more quickly and the way
that that's been done is to do shortest
distance functions over the control flow
graph to say if I'm at this basic block
and I want to be at this base block
what's the shortest path to reach that
other basic block that's a little bit
difficult because you have to
disambiguate function call returns you
have to deal with pointers and things
like that so we took a similar approach
where we would prune the control flow
graph during model checking and then do
the shortest path analysis and that
heuristic has gotten some nice
improvements over other heuristics for
for guided modal chicken and that's
nehru missed work and our future work is
to get all the variables for a given
valuation and basically this forward
simulation which i think i think a
better name for it would just be
concrete execution so this concrete
execution step in model checking in
retrospect there's no reason to do that
only partially the way to exit because
in model checking we're going to do it
all the way to the exit anyway so in
that when we stop model checking and do
this concrete execution to prune the
control flow graph we might as well go
all the way to the exit save the program
States we got and then just replay them
again when we model check all the way to
the exit using concrete execution and so
it turns out if you play the game
that way then you can get all of the
dead variables for a given valuation and
if you play some games with how you
manage the information you can make it
even more efficient and that's what Joel
self is doing for his master's thesis
all right so I kind of want to switch
gears a little bit and talk about an
idea for component abstraction that
builds on the idea of data abstraction
without transition instruction so the
idea is that we have an abstract
component inside of a concrete piece of
software so rather than taking a
component and verifying it wold flip to
the next line so rather than the typical
approach is to take some software that
surrounds a component and abstract it
and create an environment which over
approximates the actual surrounding
software and then to verify some
concrete software component inside that
abstract surrounding environment and the
surrounding the whole software artifact
is usually embedded in an abstract
execution environment which describes
like what a user is going to give it or
what some other system is going to give
it so we're thinking it would be a good
idea to abstract the software component
and leave the surrounding software
concrete and the reason that's a good
idea is because let's say that the
software system one is trying to verify
is say the transaction manager in jboss
so the transaction manager is
sufficiently complicated that you
probably that a data abstraction is a
good idea there and the surrounding
software is sufficiently complicated
that abstracting it's going to be a
difficult problem so the idea is to
leave it concrete and then deal with the
software inside of it abstractly and
that's easier to do if you if the data
abstraction for the software component
doesn't change the transition relation
because then when a state progresses
outside of the software component and we
have to see what the surrounding
software is going to do with a
particular program state if this the
abstract of software component is
dealing with the concrete transition
relation anyway then the pass off of
verification but over this boundary is a
little simpler I'll describe that in a
more detail in a second so the thing
that makes this work is a abstraction
that Karina Pasian to publish
in cab last year and her her idea goes
something like this you used the
concrete transition relation so there's
no transition abstraction and she uses
an abstract Trent abstract state
matching which basically looks like
looks like hash compaction in model
checking except instead of using a hash
function so hash compaction you take a
big program state hash it down to a
smaller value and then store that value
as the representation of that state if
more than one states hash to the same
value then they just collide in the hash
table you miss some behaviors and you
get an under approximation like tom was
talking about so Karina's idea was well
you know rather than using a hash
function that's just like deal dealing
with bits and numbers and bit patterns
why don't we use a set of predicates to
have to abstract the states and then
store a bit vector in the hash table
that represents the truth values of
those of those predicates over the state
vector so it's a little bit more of a
semantically aware compression scheme
and if you connect it with a theorem
prover you can do things like you can
determine when two states collided in a
way that mrs. behavior and as she she
has a paper about a kneecap this year
like I was saying so the way that works
is here's a little program looks like
before except I didn't play games with
the guard of the while loop if you
abstract that with this predicate x is
greater than zero then you get a
concrete face that looks like this the
way I've drawn this is that the number
on the left side of the colon is the
program location and the number on the
right side is the value of x so the
program just marches along merrily
incrementing X under this particular
abstraction scheme there's only a single
predicate so I've written the program
location along with the predicate value
so the program marches along in program
location 1 X is initially of the
predicate p is initially false still
false in location too because it's just
a evaluation of a guard becomes true in
location 3 still true when we come back
to location to increment X again
incrementing X when X is already greater
than 0 leaves x greater than 0 which
means that the predicate p is still
satisfied so the way that the
abstraction scheme works is that I'm now
back in program location 3 with
predicate p evaluating too true and i've
already seen that state before so i'm
done so i actually miss all the rest of
the behaviors of the program as x
continues to be incremented so rather
than using predicates to create an over
approximation of the state space you end
up with an under approximation of the
stage space and if you now that's not
really like a feature of this
abstraction scheme the feature of this
abstraction scheme is that you don't
have to abstract the transitions in the
program under test in fact you can
connect this up with our estes model
checker and use gdb to provide the
semantics of the program under test and
still do a predicate based data
abstraction scheme which i think is
really cool but then so for this
component abstraction idea so we have an
abstract software component with an
abstract transition relation if you were
to abstract the transition relation this
is a program state this isn't meandering
through the abstracted software
component and when verification reaches
the boundary between abstract and
concrete there's there's a bit of an
issue here because this program state is
just a list of predicates in their
valuation those predicates and their
valuations may correspond to multiple
concrete program states they need you to
give into the concrete surrounding
software so for example other parts of
jboss don't know how to execute on
predicates they just execute on concrete
data values and there's a large set of
concrete data values that might satisfy
a given set of predicates all those need
to be sent through the surrounding
software and there's a bit of a
complexity explosion there so if the
transition relation is not abstracted so
now i have an abstract software
component with a concrete transition
relation then here's my abstract state
it kind of meanders through the
component when it reaches a boundary
I'll I let me back up here's a concrete
state because I'm executing concrete
states on the concrete transition
relation and when I store them in my
table of visited states I abstract them
first so that's a bit of a sorry about
that so here's my concrete state
meandering through these abstract
software component when I reach the
surrounding software I have a concrete
state that's being executed by the
concrete transition relation so I just
pass it off to the surrounding software
nothing happens so it works out pretty
slick
so eventually execution meanders through
the surrounding software back to the
abstract component I see a new concrete
state inside the component I run it
through the abstraction function check
to see if I've seen it as an abstract
state before if I have then execution
stops otherwise execution continues to
meander through the component so it's um
it's a way of doing a predicate based of
scrap abstraction scheme on a component
inside the surrounding software that we
think will give a component-based
abstraction that will scale to large
software artifacts because i only have
to mess with the well I don't I don't I
don't have to even abstract the
transition relation of the component I
want to verify and I don't have to
extract the surrounding software which
is good when the surrounding software is
say 20 or 30 files full of Java classes
that's right the reddit the I guess
that's orange the orange are you just
kind of execute through which is good
because jboss is supposed to run fast
right so when model checking goes
through the orange area it's just
executing Java without anything so I
can't really say one of the drawbacks of
this approach though is that I can't
really say anything about errors that
are caused by behaviors of the
surrounding software because I haven't
really kept track of the behavior of the
surrounding software so if I do find an
error inside the component that I'm
trying to verify error trace generation
is going to be a little tricky because I
haven't really kept track of the trace
through here unless I do so now I'm
going to think about how I'm going to
keep track of the trace through here how
much I've I'm going to store things
that's true but if i did a depth-first
search i would need to keep concrete
states on the q states waiting to be
expanded and so I could just unwind that
I'm sorry stack that I could just unwind
that step so so what we're thinking is
the data abstraction without transition
abstraction can complement normal
predicate abstraction gives us a way of
dealing with complex data operations
because we don't have to understand what
transitions do in the first place and we
think it gives an interesting way to
verify components and complex software
this work right here that I just talked
about components and complex software
this is a work under progress so you
know this is just an idea that we're
thinking about in pursuing so this is
the work that we're currently working on
here's my contact information and that's
the end of my talk there's any questions
I'll be happy to take
well comment about the dynamic bed brave
sure while you were talking I just
realize that if you were to always do
your word execution step like even if
you don't do it all the way if you only
did it for the complete branch that
males produce enough results so that you
have something instead of saying five
steps and you're in the middle of a
branch and you stop your execute you
mean all the way to the end of a basic
block yeah sure so I don't understand so
you're saying that rather than just
doing the Ford simulation or the
concrete execution to an arbitrary point
in the program you just do it till you
reach the end of a basic block and
interesting I'm not sure how superblocks
would be an advantage in model checking
but I that that was meant to be a
question for you guys but we can talk
about that offline yet any other
questions
okay thank you